when I had those buzz slam hard I knew
it was for real I feel confused I feel
betrayed I feel overwhelmed I feel
silenced what just happened
how could they send me here I don't
belong here
how could they make such a huge mistake
without any repercussions whatsoever to
their actions
I see large groups of women in tattered
uniform surrounded by huge walls and
gates and closed by iron barbed wires
and I get hit by an awful stench and I
ask myself how did I move from walking
in the respected financial banking
sector having worked so hard in school
to now being locked up in the largest
Correctional Facility for women in Kenya
my first night at Langara women maximum
security prison was the toughest in
January of 2009 I was informed that I
had handled a fraudulent transaction and
knowingly at the bank where I walked I
was shocked scared and terrified I would
lose a career that I loved passionately
but that was not the worst it even got
worse than I could have ever imagined I
got arrested
maliciously charged and prosecuted the
absurdity of it all was the arresting
officer asking me to pay him ten
thousand US dollars and the case would
disappear I refused two and a half years
on in and out of courts fighting to
prove my innocence it was all over the
media in the newspapers TV radio they
came to me again this time round say to
me if you give us fifty thousand US
dollars the judgment will be in your
favor irrespective of the fact that
there was no evidence whatsoever that I
had any wrongdoing on the charges that I
was up against
I remember the events of my conviction
six years ago as if it were yesterday
the cold had faith of the judge as she
pronounced my sentence on a cold
Thursday morning for a crime that I
hadn't committed I remember holding my
three-month-old beautiful daughter whom
I had just named Omar which in my
dialect means truth and justice as that
was what I had longed so much for all
this time dressed her in half a bright
purple dress and here she was about to
accompany me to serve this one-year
sentence behind bars the gods did not
seem sensitive to the trauma that this
experience was causing me my
dignity and humanity disappeared with
the admission process it involved me
being such tough contrivance changed
from my ordinary clothes to the prison
uniform forced to squat on the ground a
posture that I'd soon came to LAN would
form the routine of the thousands of
such as number counts that lay ahead of
me
the women told me you'll adjust to this
place you'll fit right in
I was no longer referred to as Tara's
Njoroge the number four one five stroke
eleven was my new identity and I soon
learned that was the case with the other
women who we were sharing this space
with and I just I did - life on the
inside the prison food the prison
language the prison life prison is
certainly no fairy tale world what I
didn't see come my way was the women and
children whom we served time and shared
space with women who had been imprisoned
for crimes of the system the corruption
that requires a fall guy a scapegoat so
that the person who's responsible could
go through a broken system that
routinely vilified the vulnerable the
poorest a monsters people who cannot
afford to pay bill or brides
and so we moved on as I listened to
story after story of these close to 700
women during that one year in prison I
soon realized that crime was not what
had brought these women to prison
most of them far from it it had started
with the education system who supply and
quality is not equal for all lack of
economic opportunities that pushes this
women to petty survival crimes the
Health System social justice system the
criminal justice system if any of this
women who are mostly from poor
backgrounds fall through the cracks in
the already broken system the bottom of
that chasm is a prison period by the
time I completed my one-year sentence at
Langara women maximum prison I had a
burning conviction to be part of the
transformation to resolve the in
justices that I had witnessed of women
and girls who were caught up in a
revolving door of a life of in and out
of prison due to poverty after my
release I set up clean start clean start
is a social enterprise that seeks to
give these women and girls a second
chance what we do is we build bridges
for them we go into the prisons train
them give them skills tools and support
to enable them to be able to change
their mindsets their behaviors and their
attitudes we also build
bridges into the prisons from the
corporate sector individuals
organizations that could partner with
clean shot to enable us provide
employment places to call home jobs
vocational training for these women
girls boys and men upon transition back
into society I never thought that one
day I would be giving stories of the in
justices that are so common within the
criminal justice system but Here I am
every time I go back to prison
I feel Allie at home but it is the
daunting walk to achieve the vision that
keeps me awake at night
connecting the miles to Louisiana which
is deemed as the incarceration capital
of the world carrying with me stories of
hundreds of women whom I have met within
the prisons some of whom are now
embracing their second chances and
others who are still on that bridge of
life's journey
I am body-aline
from the great Maya Angelou I come as
one bur I stand as 10,000
for my story is singular
but imagine with me the millions of
people in prisons today yearning for
freedom three years post my conviction
and two years post my release I got
cleared by the court of appeal of any
wrongdoing around the same time I got
blessed with my son whom I named who
which in my dialect means freedom
because I had finally gotten the freedom
that I saw longed for I come as one
where I stand as 10,000 encouraged by
the hard-edged
hope that thousands of us have come
together to reform and transform the
criminal justice system encouraged that
we are doing our jobs as we are meant to
do them and let us keep doing them with
no apology thank you
[Applause]